Congestive heart failure occurs when the
heart is no longer an effective pump.
It's the single most
expensive ICD-9 code, so
there's great interest in
improving our care of it.
Early on, the symptoms are subtle,
so it may not be diagnosed for
some time, even after they begin.
Since earlier treatment can
forestall expensive complications,
earlier diagnosis is preferable.
To help with this, researches first
analyze electronic patient records,
including the parts that were free text,
such as the patient reported symptoms.
They developed feature extraction
algorithms, as illustrated here,
that use the structured and
text components to develop a set of
from 10 to 100,000 clinical features.
These were classified using
both logistic regression,
a statistical technique commonly used
to predict whether a patient has
a condition based on characteristics
of the patient, and random forests.
Which is a method that uses multiple
methods to classify objects.
This determined which features
are in fact predictive.
As shown here, the resulting
model substantially outperforms
the diagnosis of CHF based solely
on the medical literature, when as
few as 50 features with high predictive
power based on the model are added.